in India we have these huge families I
bet a lot of you must have heard about
it which means that there are a lot of
family events so as a child my parents
used to drag me to these family events
but the one thing that I always looked
forward to was playing around with my
cousins and there was always this one
uncle who used to be there always ready
jumping around with us having games for
us making us kids have the time of our
lives
this man was extremely successful he was
confident and powerful but then I saw
this hale and hearty person deteriorate
in health he was diagnosed with
Parkinson's Parkinson's is a disease
that causes degeneration of the nervous
system which means that this person who
used to be independent suddenly finds
tasks like drinking coffee because of
tremors much more difficult my uncle
started using a walker to walk and to
take a turn he literally had to take one
step at a time like this and it took
forever so this person who used to be
the center of attention in every family
gathering was suddenly hiding behind
people he was hiding from the pitiful
look in people's eyes and he's not the
only one in the world every year 60,000
people are newly diagnosed with
Parkinson's and his numbers only rising
as designers we dream that our design
solved these multifaceted problems one
solution that solves at all but it need
not always be like that you can also
target simple problems and create small
solutions for them and eventually make a
big impact so my aim here was to not
cure Parkinson's but to make their
everyday tasks much more simpler and
then make an impact
well the
first thing I targeted with tremors
right my uncle told me that he had
stopped drinking coffee or tea in public
just out of embarrassment so but I
designed the know spelled cup it works
just purely on its form the curve on top
deflects the liquid back inside every
time they have tremors and this keeps
the liquid inside compared to a normal
cup but the key here is that it is not
tagged as a Parkinson's patient product
it looks like a cup that could be used
by you me any clumsy person and that
makes it much more comforting for them
to use to blend in so well one problem
solved many more to go all this while I
was interviewing him questioning him and
then I realized that I was getting very
superficial information or just answers
to my questions but I really needed to
dig deeper to get a new perspective so I
thought well let's observe him in his
daily tasks while he's eating while he's
watching TV and then when I was actually
observing him walking to his dining
table it struck me this man who finds it
so difficult to walk on flatland
how does he climb a staircase because in
India we do not have a fancy rail that
takes you up a staircase like in the
developed countries one actually has to
climb the stairs so he told me well let
me show you how I do it let's take a
look at what I saw so he took really
long to reach this position and then all
this while I'm thinking oh my god is he
really gonna do it is he really really
going to do it without his walker and
then
and the turns he took them so easily so
shocked well I was too so this person
who could not walk on flatland was
suddenly a pro at climbing stairs on
researching this I realized that it's
because it's a continuous motion there's
this other man who also suffers from the
same symptoms and uses a walker but the
moment he is put on a cycle all his
symptoms vanish
because it is a continuous motion so the
key for me was to translate this feeling
of walking on a staircase back to
flatland and a lot of ideas were tested
and tried on him but the one that
finally worked was this one let's take a
look he walked faster right
I call this the staircase illusion and
actually when the staircase illusion
abruptly ended he froze and this is
called freezing of gait
so it happens a lot so why not have a
staircase illusion flowing through all
their rooms making them feel much more
confident you know technology is not
always it what we need are human
centered solutions I could have easily
made it into a projection or a Google
glass or something like that but I stuck
to simple prints on the floor the sprint
could be taken into hospitals to make
them feel much more welcomed what I wish
to do is to make every Parkinson's
patient feel like my uncle felt that day
he told me that I made him feel like his
old self again smart in today's world
has become synonymous to high tech and
the world and only getting smarter and
smarter day by day but why can't smart
be something that's simple and yet
effective all we need is a little bit of
empathy and some curiosity to go out
there observe but let's not stop with
that let's find these complex problems
don't be scared of them break them boil
them down into much smaller problems and
then find simple solutions for them test
these solutions well fail if needed but
with newer insights to make it better
imagine what we all could do if we all
came up with simple solutions what would
the world be like if we combined all the
simple solutions let's make a smarter
world but with simplicity thank
you